[Musique]
je
temps
[Musique]
jamais marcher comme ça sur la plage
entre garçons c'est
non jamais il était temps tu le
rencontres talent évoqué un trou c'est
cool non
c'est très joli chez vous son devenir
tu mme bokova de nouveaux copains ils
vouvoient j'ai l'impression d'être une
dame j'adore je continuais de l'état un
copie elle va dormir ici
non je te le dis vous savez qu'on est au
21ème siècle
il ya des choses qu'on pas bougé un des
plus grands manieurs falloir que je la
joue fine et cloud
si je vais annoncer ça de but en blanc
est capable de me balancer dans la salle
du deuxième étage
non
[Musique]
disons rien d'aller croquer jaussaud
avant l'actuelle en géorgie toi jupe
hors jeu je vous demande touche mais mon
expérience aux services de bercy
wwa est la mort fait madonna
[Applaudissements]